president biden was asked friday if he
will attend the queen's funeral
you're going to the queen's funeral sir
yes
i don't know what the details are yet
but i will be going have you called the
uh
i know him i haven't spoken to him i did
not call him yet
in her lifetime queen elizabeth met with
13 u.s presidents the first was harry
truman when she was still a princess
after her coronation she met with 12
more presidents the exception being
lyndon johnson they only corresponded
now it's time for king charles iii to
continue the tradition christina raffini
is at the white house christina good
morning
good morning and of course you heard
that pretty unequivocable yes from
president biden remember he met with the
queen during his first big international
trip after kovit and after the meeting
he said she reminded him of his mother
both in appearance and demeanor now the
queen is one of the few people to have a
longer tenure in public office than
president biden but he also will find he
has some things in common with her
successor the new king charles both men
are about the same age and both men had
to wait and wait and wait decades in the
wings before finally getting the big job
in their 70s now the queen's funeral is
not a service that we can expect many
world leaders will want to miss but it's
especially important for the american
president to be there given that
so-called special relationship between
the two countries
and the fact that the uk has not only a
new monarch but a new prime minister liz
truss whose meeting with the queen was
the sovereign's final official act
before her death so while of course
there is a family in mourning there's
also a new monarchy to define global
politics to grapple with and although it
was a symbolic position it was a
position that meant a lot to a lot of
people and of course that's why we
expect to see president biden at that
service dana
all right christina thank you